you
Turkey and the United States have a
relationship that goes back decades but
it's also a relationship that's seen a
number of ups and downs
including July 2016 s failed coup by a
group within the Turkish military
Turkey's labor minister went as far as
accusing the United States of being
behind the coup Turkey's government is
also upset that the US hasn't yet
extradited pennsylvania-based Turkish
cleric fettling Gulen who they claim
orchestrated the coup but the US turkey
relationship is far too important for
both sides to be upset at each other
forever and here's why in recent times
the u.s. turkish alliance has proven
critical to both sides on the
battlefield
the US has relied on Turkey for years to
support its foreign policy in the region
turkey served as a base of operations
during the 1995 bosnian war the 1999
kosovo war and the 2001 of on us on war
and while turkey refused to allow the
u.s. to invade iraq from its territory
or commit troops to coalition forces it
did allow the u.s. use to injure like
base during the war but it doesn't end
there the u.s. designated longtime
Turkish state enemy the Kurdistan
Workers Party or the PKK as terrorists
the PKK is a Kurdish left-wing
separatist group and has been involved
in an armed struggle against Turkey for
decades and the United States also armed
Syrian rebels allied with Turkey to
weaken and bring down President Bashar
al-assad's government and it's because
of how strategically important turkey is
in the Syrian war that the relationship
between DC and Ankara has become
strained thanks to Isis
the US has accused turkey of not doing
enough to maintain its porous border
with Syria which has been the central
crossing for thousands of foreign
fighters into the war-torn country
that's the same porous border that Isis
has also used to sell oil from its
territory on the black market and as
Isis gained ground in both Syria and
Iraq tensions flared between the u.s.
and Turkey even though the US was once
again using the injure like base for
operations against the group but Turkey
has its gripes with the u.s. as well in
the fight against Isis the u.s. teamed
up with guess who yep the PKK which has
also been at the forefront of fighting
Isis and that's got turkey a little
upset as a PKK along with other Kurdish
militias continues to chip away at Isis
territory on the ground with US support
from the sky turkeys also upset with the
u.s. for not implementing a no-fly zone
along the turkey-syria border for Turkey
that no-fly zone would mean curbing the
flow of refugees across its borders
currently turkey hosts 2.7 million
refugees turkey and the u.s. are both
member states of NATO and Turkey has
served as a base for countering Soviet
and later Russian influence in the
region since 1952 and that pretty much
means that it's held some of America's
nukes on its soil
ever since that's important in case the
nuclear war ever happens to erupt
according to the Federation of American
scientists around 50 b61 nuclear bombs
are located at the inter lick base
that's a quarter of NATO's nuclear
arsenal with each bomb more than 155
times stronger than the bombs that
destroyed Hiroshima so despite all the
ups and downs the u.s. Turkish
relationship remains vital to both sides
you